Time Reports the United Nations study
out this week finds domestic violence is
one of the most common killers of women
around the world about 50,000 women were
killed in 2017 by an intimate partner or
relative on average that means about 137
women were killed every day by family
members Alex Wagner recently met with
domestic abuse survivors and has more on
this Alex good morning good morning in
the US alone an estimated one in four
women is victim of severe physical abuse
it's an epidemic we've been looking into
for months earlier this year we asked
viewers to send in submissions for our
series note to self
we found close to 100 of those notes
mentioned a history of domestic violence
two of those women are part of this
group which ranges from a municipal
judge to a former UN worker New York
Times bestselling author Bernie Sanders
former deputy campaign manager and the
president of a nonprofit foundation how
many of you didn't realize it was
happening at first I mean if you had
asked me at the time my husband was
beating me on a regular basis he had
three guns that he kept loaded all the
time he pulled them on me you know on a
very regular basis and if you would ask
me if I was a battered wife I would have
said no I'm not I'm a strong smart
independent woman who's in love with a
troubled man and I became increasingly
ashamed that I loved him and that my
love was making me vulnerable and making
me go back again and again and it wasn't
until I became really convinced that he
was going to kill me yeah I was able to
leave number of you feel like your
abusers would have killed he was trying
to kill me so there was no doubt I knew
it Laverne you have talked about the
isolation yeah that your abuser made you
choose between your family correct and
him yeah how did that happen
it was almost his body and colide
mentality that it's us against the world
because that's what I was told over and
over again he became almost like my
protector right right it's insane the
mentality that we have during the
relationship that we believe that there
is nobody else and
I was ashamed I want to talk a little
bit about that idea that you were
ashamed this horrible thing was
happening to you
and yet you were the person that was
embarrassed and ashamed Rania you're a
high-powered woman in politics tell me
about how you grappled with what was
happening to you
not very well working in a predominantly
male environment where I was constantly
fighting for my seat at the table where
I was constantly fighting to be
respected I was terrified that someone
would find out and then the struggle
that I was already having to go through
in my professional life was just going
to be that much worse at what point
could you no longer keep it together
honestly I don't know how long it would
have lasted had one of my she's a sister
she's my friend but she's really as my
sister she saw the bruises on me and she
called me and said I know what's
happening and he's never going to touch
you again
it's incredibly hard to leave somebody
who has such a powerful psychological
hold on you I want to talk it's not just
psychological right I mean only so you
endured a number of forms of abuse
including financial abuse yeah that's
one thing I wanted to stress is the
financial abuse I mean if you don't have
a black guy people think well you really
weren't abused you know I I think his
jealousy I thought at first was you know
that he really cared and and then it
just became a point where it was like he
owned me I really felt that he believed
I felt yes like I was his car property
right exactly I mean if I would try to
go visit my family he would take my
credit card out of my wallet I had moved
out of the house with my child he was
supposed to pay child support pay the
mortgage he did neither for a while
during this time because there's so much
pressure on you did you think maybe I
should just go back to him no never you
were resolute I was resolute how many of
you questioned whether you had made the
right decision at any more oh my gosh
not one day wait you went back I went
back the first time my children was
small it was more physical than than
at the end at the end it was more verbal
but I went back I left him for a year
and I said well else you promise not to
hit me anymore I'll come back to you did
you really think he was gonna stop
hitting you no but I had to do something
for my babies a lot of people hear
stories of domestic abuse and they they
don't understand why why you stayed they
keep asking the question well why did
you stay how do we need to reframe
Mackel I think the question would be why
does he think he can do that and get
away with it
correct we tend to sometimes think that
we let it happen I don't of course in my
the first time he slapped me I saw stars
that's how hard he slapped me and he
stormed out and I'm sitting there and I
asked myself that question how could you
let this but of course he didn't and
people actually confusing me to have
love and violence code to get all it
just like co2 today they beat the crap
out of you and then for me I know I'm
sure he would then put his arms around
me and say stop crying I'm here for the
person who manages you is also healing
yes but he sort of asked one big
question as we close this out we are
having this conversation against a much
broader backdrop of accountability
sexual relations sexual harassment
sexual predation power control control
are you all more optimistic that we can
put an end to domestic violence given
the national conversation that we're
having right now I am so optimistic
journalists are listening the media is
listening police officers the quartz law
it's not gonna change overnight but I am
tremendously optimistic I'm from a very
small community some people are going to
say why did you air your dirty laundry
ha ha and I say if it says one woman's
life then let the laundry hang out we
reached out to Judy's ex-husband he
didn't deny the allegations and said
that he believes abuse goes both ways
the National Domestic Violence hotline
told us that the first step in getting
out of an abusive situation is to have a
safety plan a plan to prepare to leave a
plan when you
leave and a plan after you leave also it
is critically important to reach out to
someone anyone it doesn't need to be law
enforcement it could be a friend a
family member or even a complete
stranger you know so important that you
did that look somebody is listening to
that right now well and that's
resonating with somebody right now and
that's going to help them remember years
ago my mom told me love is not supposed
to hurt ya and physically or emotionally
and I've never forgotten it's not your
fault yes right I can i underscore that
somebody's now saying it's not just me
just like a lot of those women who in
their note to self
you know you there's a community of
people who are have the exact same
experience that piece is so important
for those people that feel I am NOT
alone because it's a loneliness that
keeps you encased in those relationships
work memory through whatever stereotype
people have of an abuse victim get out
they are not any case wrong that's all
or it's silly educated it can happen to
anyone can she said I was in love with
the troubled man mm-hmm just change our
thinking about that they are the
aggressors exactly thank you the
National Domestic Violence hotline has
counselors available around the clock so
if you or someone you know needs help
that number is